today I'm joined in studio by writer and
political commentator Bethany Mandel to
talk about her work on North Korea
having babies on the side of the highway
and how the experience of big government
can make you into a conservative yes
even you then roaming millennial and
Cassie Dylan joined the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss our impending
war with North Korea the soon to be
deported Dhaka dreamers and the Georgia
schoolteacher who banned make America
great again t-shirts from her classroom
and you pay her salary taxpayers
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Doyle show
[Music]
so we're very lucky we have Bethany
Mandel and today one of the best
commentators out there really fun to
read you can read you anywhere basically
but at the Federalist a lot of other
places of carriage of writing I want to
delve right into this what are you doing
in Los Angeles already in North Korea
which is an organization that when
people when refugees escape over the
border from North Korea into China they
if they're in China and they're caught
in China by Chinese authorities or by
someone else in China they're either
sent back to North Korea where they're
put in death camps or they're killed or
or they're put into sex trafficking if
they're women so Liberty North Korea has
networks in northern China and they are
able to identify these refugees and help
them traverse 3,000 miles through an
underground railroad from northern China
into South Korea where they have
automatic citizenship but that 3,000
mile trip costs about $3,000 so over the
last five years I've just sort of as a
Jewish person I felt like I need to do
something because this is not a
Holocaust but it's so similar because of
the camps and because of the the
dictatorship and the the mass death
that's happened so many instances over
over the last decades the negligence the
international negligence yeah of the
issue yeah no one seems to care that
there's death camps the size of Los
Angeles in North Korea so I started
fundraising for them five years ago I
remember very vividly first learning
about Rwanda when I was a kid and I
asked my mom you know what did you do as
if my mom could have done something cuz
you're okay do you think like my mom
should be able to fix this and so we
were trying to have a baby and I said
well I need to be able to say that I
need to say something to my kid so I
started fundraising for North Korea five
years ago when we started trying to have
a baby and over the last five years I've
raised enough to rescue seventeen
refugees from from China Wow you're
being a little humble too you're not
just out here to go have dinner or
something you're being honored for your
work
yes honoring me at their gala on
Saturday night Wow that's this seems
like the best charity it's see I'm yeah
I do remember reading about it once and
having that same reaction like why
doesn't everybody just flood their money
into this Liberty North Korean and how I
first heard about them is I read every
nob every memoir that I can find from
all of these these defectors and by
writing all of these memoirs they're
opening the world's eyes to what's
happening in North Korea and it's such
an incredible way to make the world care
when they don't seem to want to so
you're not just rescuing a life which is
incredibly valuable in and of itself but
you're also helping open the world's
eyes to these atrocities and hoping
hopefully saving people one of the
things I love about you and about your
writing is that you don't just talk the
talk you walk it - I try you try you try
- that's all we can do so a lot of
conservatives all the time they talk
about how we need to be more charitable
but I don't know how charitable every
conservative is a lot of times they'll
talk about how we need to have babies we
need to have a family we need to have
Family Values that's the building block
of society and yet so many of the
commentators and the politicians are
single or they they don't really have
kids I might have experienced that
debauchery once upon a time it's crazy I
mean yeah the biggest
hookup and party on nobody would believe
it because it's so much Brooks Brothers
and bowties but once the lights go out
it what is it the Reagan Palooza yeah I
I mean I don't consider myself sheltered
at all but the first time I went to
Reagan Palooza I was horrified like I
used to go to raves in Europe and see
people hooking up in pools you don't
hear a really gross story please always
I'm just gonna tell you everybody enjoy
this one my awesome flame out watching I
went to a rave at a bathhouse in
Budapest and I was like I'm gonna go
swimming this is great and I ended up
getting chlamydia in my eye
all the ways I thought that would end
that's worse even though there was no
benefit someone was having fun in the
pool and I had antibiotic antibiotic
resistant chlamydia mi I do regular bowl
to get rid of four years is gonna put me
on like a serious set of antibiotics
carrot event you can say what you want
about CPAC I went through a lot of
debauchery there I never got chlamydia
in my eye Wow you aren't parting I know
I didn't you're making me nostalgic for
all those bright college years that's so
but the point is I've seen debauchery in
person and I became conservative because
I didn't want to see those things right
in my daily life and then I went to
Reagan blues and I was like you know I
wonder too if it's especially among the
Beltway the young Republican types there
is an emphasis I think on I'm a fiscal
conservative but a social liberal
McColgan
it's really not social liberalism as
much as like I I would love some
premarital yeah I'm a libertine yeah
that's it yeah which you know who can
blame them but you you don't do that
you're living this at and you just had a
kid Mazel Tov thank you
you just had a kid on the side of a
highway I did not on purpose I tweeted
actually pure Piers Morgan tweeted
yesterday how he was hosting some
British something or other I think it
was I think it's the title and he's like
I'm doing it with three broken ribs and
so I clapped back and I tweeted I had a
baby I didn't I'm home baby on the side
of the highway tough guy I try to hold
that card like I don't play it at every
moment but I was like this is gonna be
the moment where I'm gonna put that card
and like 9,000 people have like that
tweet and I was like alright that was
pretty much it well deserve yeah so this
isn't just some baby this is a 9-pound
baby nine pound no medicine no drugs so
I planned on doing that I was like using
midwives and I'm sort of hippie-dippie
on birth and my other two kids were also
like natural whatever not because I love
pain but because needles scared the
daylights out of me I don't really want
a needle in my spine
and I was telling you like when I was
pregnant with my first well when I was
having her in labor
ie become paranoid and crazy when you're
in labor and so I got it in my head that
they were all trying to just slip me an
epidural and sorry start screaming like
no drugs get away from me don't touch me
I don't want drugs and they were like we
never heard a woman say that yeah never
yeah and you sound like a lady who's on
drugs you didn't get out of here don't
bring one so I had two natural births
already which the benefit of that was I
knew what it felt like and so it wasn't
like I might have to poop on the side of
the road like no I'm gonna have a baby
right now on the side of the road and I
I mean we shouldn't have chosen a
hospital that was 45 minutes later
lessons learned for the fourth kitten so
now you're on your third yeah and I just
I met little Altima that's the name yeah
he was born in India Sean Altima Nissan
okay clean the car for free that was
generous really Jen well appreciate it
yes do you find in in your life it's so
strange to have a lot of kids now it's
strange kids at a young age
it's strange especially you're in a sort
of intellectual comment area it's it's
just not common anymore
yeah what are the pros and cons of
propagating our way into political power
there are no cons except you might
accidentally have a baby on the side of
the road that's gone but you don't
regret anything you don't you don't have
a day where you are ripping your hair
out and saying I wish that I were living
in some Manhattan pentest working in a
bank yeah you know it's funny I have
those seconds where like well I I did a
thousand mile road trip two weeks ago
with my kids alone my husband couldn't
take off the work yeah
so he came with me on this trip so he
didn't have that much vacation time and
then we had a week between thousand mile
road trip and Aleya
which is six hours on a plane with three
kids under 4 and and so my kids of
course were sick that week in between
which I mean I'll take that versus on
the either end and still like one kid is
vomiting the other kid has 102 fever the
other kid
like coughing I remember and I only way
to make this worse is to get chlamydia
everything else it's pretty tough yeah
and so I was like I had a moment where I
said you know why am I doing this and
then I have a girlfriend I have a
million girlfriends who are still single
and want to have kids and I'm leaving
their dream life and even though the
dream life isn't awesome at every moment
of the day no life is awesome at every
moment of the day but I mean I have a
really sweet situation I'm a
stay-at-home mom I'm home with my three
kids and they're my they're my job and
everything else is just sort of a side
hustle but and that's what if excited a
Silurian and so I mean I make it work by
I show up at the Daily wire with my four
month old because I am breastfeeding and
he won't take formula and I don't pop so
like here we are I've recently been
talking to my fiance sweet little ELISA
about this because a lot of our
conservative friends are having a lot of
kids now and they live in the middle of
nowhere and in New York where I'm from
that is totally unheard of it is or
we're even getting married it's sort of
a young age but I want a norm and I lady
never tells
I'm 27 okay so I got married when I was
25 I think or 24 and and you know -
you're from New Jersey
yeah it's unheard of yeah bad there yeah
so I wear Orthodox shoes so it's it's
more normal like my husband was sort of
a spinster spinster when we got married
he was 29 I think when we got there Seth
the spinster yeah yeah and so people
were starting you're wondering like
what's that's the deal married yet he
was just yeah waiting for a soul mate
waiting waiting for the right one to
come along yeah who will let him have a
baby on the side of the road and he gets
deliberate and be the hero and speaking
this is a little apropos of nothing but
I was reminded of it when I talked about
how you're in New Jersey and I'm from
Newark we also we have another similar
experience our your mother died when you
were 16 yeah my mother died when I was
17
yeah we both interacted with the federal
government in Medicaid and Social
Security all of those agencies yeah that
made you more conservative it may be
conservative period my my mom was the
most liberal person ever except for guns
we had a lot of guns
here if I was telling Alicia I'm saying
with Alicia Krauss and so I was telling
her we had a shotgun in every corner of
our living room loaded it's just laying
and I remember this at 4 years old this
is in Jersey
so I'm from New York and I would like to
make that very clear
I will live in New Jersey but I am from
New York and I'm is a difference in
mindset yes I'm a temporary resident of
New Jersey and whenever I can flee I
will yeah I'm working on my husband on
that front been a few years but yeah so
my mom was really liberal and and I
remember when my first memories is is
giving the finger to abortion protesters
and she was like she had had abortions
and she was proud of it she was one of
those kinds of women and I sort of went
into my childhood with I was a big al
gore supporter and I had his bumper
stickers on my locker in middle school
you are the only student in the United
States whoever at Al Gore bumper sticker
part of it was because he had a Jewish
running mate and I had sort of like the
Jewish pride like Joe Lieberman he's one
of us I do love Joe Lieberman he is if
he had been at the top of the ticket I
still would never have supported them
but he's a really decent guy he's a
decent guy yeah he's to belong to our
synagogue on in DC and I used to sort of
like channel 13 year old Bethenny and
fangirl and we would it's like there
there's a nosh thing at the end of
synagogue on Saturday afternoon and the
first time I saw him I was like for some
13 year old girls it's Justin Timberlake
for others it's Joe Lieberman I have an
old man thing I really do and Seth has a
beard now and I made him grow it and he
has these like gray hairs and it just
hubba-hubba for a certain person yeah
he's still my beating oh yes so you're
16 right sorry mother died and you were
lost you have to deal with you govern
you have to deal with my dad but your
dad was m.i.a
so you're in this impossible situation
yeah the government makes it worse yeah
yeah so I for the first year I was 16
and for the first year I bounced around
to friends and I was an exchange student
at the time so I was living in Belgium
so I just finished my exchange here cuz
I'd know where else to go
um so I came back and I had nowhere to
live because the person who was first
my guardian decided not to be my
guardian which was pretty jerky thing to
do yeah not a good time for that to
happen 16 you just lost your mother yeah
so my fairly evil aunt who I had heard
nothing but awful things for my mother
offered me her couch in New York City on
the Lower East Side and I was like yeah
I'm desperate and so she said you know I
I won't touch any of the money that I'm
getting from Social Security or child
support from your dad and and that will
be yours at the end of it cuz I had very
little inheritance and the day my check
stopped from Social Security when I
graduated high school I was kicked out
on the front steps of the Lower East
Side with and like still gives me panic
when I have like low battery on my phone
oh I forgot to charge it crap because I
had no battery I'm worried gonna charge
it yeah and I had I didn't have a
charger with me I had like two bars I
was under 10% my garbage bags and I was
just on the streets in New York City and
I went to Social Security and I told
them the whole story and that's it and
they said yeah she actually that was
fraud what she did was fraud and there
was like other parts of the story also
that that made it more fraudulent and I
said okay let's let's do it thank you
government yeah and so they said we'll
assign an investigator and we'll get it
back and I said great thank you I'm
gonna guess you're still waiting for
that investigator to show so he knocked
on her door twice and then the
investigation had to close people don't
know this if your parent dies in you're
under 18 Social Security Administration
does send a check for a little while it
used to be until you were 21 now I get
to tell you high school graduate high
school graduation and I I mean I was
lucky my my family didn't didn't steal
my money from either very good about it
but the check doesn't go to you the
check goes to somebody else and if
you're in a terrible situation like that
there it goes and then your mother like
my mother paid into Social Security all
her entire life and she worked from 16
years old and yeah so yeah and my mom
worked hot like very hard my mom was an
incredible person I'm sure yours was
also but nothing
and now the federal government has that
money there's no return on that you get
no return
so you're desperate you're basically
homeless yeah at 17 at that point 80
because you've graduated from high
school yeah and you have a political
transformation basically I so I my
freshman year of college I went and I
lived in the South Bronx cuz it was all
I could afford and my mom being wily and
smart convinced my not so wily and smart
father that when they divorced he would
have to pay child support
she gave him a choice either I don't
know 15% until she graduates high school
or 10% until she graduates whatever
school that she's done and so he was
like I'm gonna pick the lower number not
realizing that that's actually going to
be more over the course of time and
you're on the hook for longer that gets
a little fuzzy when if you're just doing
it
yeah whatever I'm not gonna so any musii
so he was on the hook to still pay me
child support when I was in college and
so I found an apartment in a roach
infested apartment first floor level in
the Bronx and it was exactly his child
support payment so he just paid my rent
instead of child support and and I
worked full-time to pay my bills and I
often didn't make my bills I walk around
with a dollar and in my wallet
five foot tall Jewish girl living in the
South Bronx yeah I had to ask my very
rich friends on the Upper West Side you
know do you have some box of the pasta
you can steal out of your parents pantry
I was really profoundly broke that year
like I really can't understate how broke
I was and I was really idealistic and I
said you know I'm gonna work in the
Bronx and I'm gonna work with students
and and I lived there and I met these
there teachers and I heard the stories
of you know on welfare
my mom had a baby every two years so she
could qualify for WIC and they didn't
know their all their kids names and
their teachers and this is all her
joking
no no every two years I remember this
kid's name to this day and this was the
stories that we're always told by the
left-wing press Ronald Reagan was making
it up the stories of the welfare queen
and people
the system but you met these people
person yeah and I went to the
supermarket and saw people buying the
junk food with their with their food
stamps and then going outside and
selling it like you if you live in New
York City you will see these things in
person and it's not hard to see them and
I had friends who were working off the
books and we're on welfare and Medicaid
and food stamps and everything and I I
was not I was I was playing it pretty by
the book and and I saw that my students
and they would talk to me about their
teachers who all of these teachers
unions protected their jobs but their
teachers would come in and say I am
working here for two years so that I can
get my loans forgiven and they'd lay
down their giant New York Times on on
the desk and they'd say everyone be
quiet for the next 45 minutes and I
don't care what you do and that's the
schools and my kids would come up to me
cuz I was I was running an after-school
program and and my the seniors who had
just graduated they had never met
someone who was in college and I was at
City College the CUNY school in New York
it was a great College it's a City
University CUNY it has great programs it
doesn't not to be a great College yeah I
mean it was it was good for what it was
honestly I paid almost nothing and so
they would come out to me and say how do
I go to college and they had just
graduated high school and I said did you
take the SATs no one told me I guess it
he's they they had never met anyone that
went to college they had no idea how to
go to college and there and they they
wanted to start a member these kids are
all products of the system yeah they're
interacting with the government with
these systems yeah every step of the way
Oh liberal controlled by the way New
York City teachers unions and they just
utterly failed that there was no none of
the incentives or lined out to get these
kids and the most basic things yeah
they're in the system since they're in
the cradle yeah and they can't show them
that you need to take the SAT yeah it
was June July and they wanted to I mean
and if you think about it if you don't
know the system if you move to a new
area you just enroll in school and you
start in September and they had no idea
that there's this hope they should have
been doing this a whole year and a half
prior to do the SATs to get the letters
of
from who by the way who were they
getting these letters of recommendation
from the New York Times history teacher
remember and as hard off as I was I had
a mom who went to college and who had a
master's degree and who instilled in me
a work ethic and and I knew and I went
to a good enough school I went to a
charter school in the Upper West Side
that I cried behind him to I showed up
and it was a school that never let kids
transferring so I got a deal by the way
I just I just cried so I sat down and I
sat across from the principal on my aunt
Eva lo she may have been actually did
help me on this I sat down across from
the principal and I you know the mom
yeah you know what happened my mother
died right after I got into Yale and su
is here it was nice that she got to see
it and but they were so immediately
responsive it was so the opposite of of
what you were described you have people
saying get out of here kid I only take
an interest in you if I can take your
money yeah so I am I one of my favorite
Rutgers stories it's this big I went to
Rutgers and it's big this big
bureaucracy it's that bastion of
conservative some records universe yeah
well you know what it made me
conservative because it's such a
bureaucracy but it makes you
conservative and I actually went to
school with James O'Keefe and we were
sort of yeah that's the whole sidebar
but we it's a huge sort of that's that's
the government but in a in a small a
microcosm yes and it this gets to my
theory you're you embodying two of these
theories which is the people who have
had slightly difficult experiences in
their life
any of them tend to lean a little bit
more right-wing yeah all the hysterical
Occupy New Haven kids in college their
fathers were all hedge fund managers of
all the people that were arrested at the
Occupy things they were like in
Southbury Connecticut or something of
course Columbia grad students and then
the other is the people who have to
interact with the government people who
have to deal with the government in an
intimate way never won big government
again in their lives yeah I mean I
remember going down to switch my address
for Medicaid cuz I was on Medicaid most
of my until I was 22
on Medicaid and I had to just change my
address and when I have private
insurance now I'm an adult and my
husband has a job that we have insurance
and when we moved I called them and I
said this is my new address this is my
this is how you can confirm it's me
here's my address and my phone number
and my social security number or
whatever and that was it
twenty seconds and on Medicaid I had to
take the train two hours down into
Brooklyn and sat there and everyone was
on their cell phones playing music for
two hours and people were giving me
their babies so they can have a smoke
break and then two hours they call my
number and I go up and and they change
my dress and it took two hours of
sitting in Brooklyn to get that done and
how are you supposed to have a full-time
job when you when that's what it is your
full-time job yeah because that's the
way that you figure out how to get
resources yeah is gaming this impossible
bureaucracy yeah now I don't before we
run out of time I do want to cover this
a little bit so you don't have an easy
life you got a little bit of a tough
life and then last year congratulations
the ADL names you one of the ten biggest
recipients of anti-semitic hatred on
Twitter yeah and now it's number one
then yeah it's true a good buddy of ours
is number one and I used to see it I
mean I would see in Ben's feet I would
see it in Drew clavin's for you I get it
a little bit even I guess my Roman nose
makes people think that I'm Jewish but
one interesting aspect of this is most
of the vast majority of these came from
1600 Twitter accounts yeah so yeah it's
something that nobody talks about nobody
talks about I always assumed having
worked a little in political operations
I always assumed it was like five people
just sitting here I think they were
Russian BOTS I mean there's been a lot
of research into when they were active
what those accounts were doing
beforehand and it frustrates me now and
I say this everywhere people ask me to
talk about it and it's a lot of places
and I say like it was probably Russians
and everyone's like well actually the
narrative is that America has been
overrun by white supremacists yeah so if
we could not do that part on air that
would be great and they have Richard
Spencer sure has this con
every year it attracts 200 people it
attracted 200 people five years ago it's
going to attract 200 people this year
maybe 210 Charlottesville was a national
protest nobody came it was Johnny and it
was licensed place from all around the
country exactly it was truly yeah and
200 of the schmucky schmuck showed up in
in Charlottesville but the whole country
I mean granted I'm not I'm not denying
that there's a white supremacist problem
and a or they're always racist yeah
there's always racist there's always
anti-semites but now it's convenient to
notice these things and its really
frustrating as a Jewish person because
whenever there's a vandalism incident
now it's national news and I'm sorry if
you pay attention to the data Jews have
always been the number one recipient of
hate crimes and it's usually vandalism
but no one wanted to talk about that
well because we didn't have Dear Leader
wasn't the president then you and I by
the way saying this as a never Trumper
like Alex right I was never a fan of
President Trump I'm still not terribly
fangirl about him but you have to be
intellectually honest about about it and
no one is it's either this is the
narrative and can you please stick to it
or your trumpian and there's no
in-between and you published this great
piece that did go viral about how we
need to befriend Nazis yeah about how
the anti became a Nazi
yeah congratulations that's an
accomplishment it was actually it's I am
yeah but I love your approach because
especially in this insanely polarized
political sound bites a low time the
only way to accomplish anything is to
take people seriously and take their
argument seriously yeah I mean and we
don't necessarily have to all be friends
right making absolutely disagreement is
a lovely thing yeah but there I mean not
nearly as much with white supremacist as
much an neo-nazis but people can't even
have a conversation like I've lost
friends on both sides of the spectrum
I've lost friends because I am a
trumpian now and I've lost friends
because I'm a snowflake liberals because
everybody is a nots
right when everybody's a Nazi that
nobody isn't exactly and that's what I
read I don't know if I was reading too
deeply into the headline on your piece
but I read it as is on the one hand
saying we should talk to these not 20
people who were insane try to change
their hearts yeah but on the other side
you we think that everybody who
disagrees with this as a nod yeah
there's that meme that it says how to
argue on the Internet everyone I
disagree with is a Nazi yeah and so if
you think someone's a Nazi maybe speak
to them understand my previous column
for the foreword the week before which
is a like part of people just read the
two headlines and my headline for the
last week was don't try to out Nazis
because your rights depend on theirs and
it's not just sort of your free speech
rights and and everyone with every every
disgusting person has a right to speech
as long as it's not violent
but it's also and I also said that as
conservatives we are constantly called
Nazis and I'm I don't support destroying
people's lives for being Nazis because
your definition of Nazi is really
frickin broad that's right
and I wrote this column and of course
nobody read it because everyone only
reads the headlines and so people read
that and then read the we should be
friendly or Nazis thing and and I've
spent two weeks being called a Nazi on
Twitter and I was like you're actually
proving my point
if you read the column which certainly
they did and I will say you're one of
the loveliest Nazis I've ever met thank
you now in typical Michael Knowles show
fashion we need to bring on more women
we do not have enough women on the show
right now so we need to bring on the one
and only roaming millennial and Cassie
Dylan or both here for the panel of
deplorable z-- ladies thank you for
coming on hi thanks for having us so we
now we need to talk about we've been
speaking at length but let's go back to
North Korea Oh actually you know what
first actually for I want to get to that
but I don't want to get to it yet I
first want to talk about all these kids
because especially once you bring women
on your show you just need to start
talking about families are obviously
we're all going to be Sister Wives at
some point as the nurturing bearers of
life and the hands that rock the cradle
which will rule the world is
homeschooling the way that conservatives
should go we I know that I know that you
homeschool your kids Bethany a lot of
conservatives are doing it now there are
these crazy stories coming out of public
schools what what are your thoughts
roaming well I actually I wasn't
necessarily homeschooled but my later
years with high school when I was about
14 to 16 I did independent study so my
parents weren't me I was doing just
passes through a university but it kind
of amounted to the same thing I was
actually going to the school and for the
longest time before I even had a concept
of what service system was there before
I was politically involved I've always
known that I wanted to homeschool my
children and that's just my experiences
from public schools just being in that
situation I I've known for a young age
that is not what I want my children have
and for me if the question is not
whether I'm going to home-school
children about how early I'm going to
start because I really do want to
homeschool them I think would be a
better environment and it's not only
safer the values like key symbols for
academic challenge however I don't want
them it appeared that is a struggle
Cassie are you was roaming are you gonna
homeschool your kids well I went to a
public school and then after high school
and actually during high school as well
I worked at an after-school program and
I think that the program I worked at it
was private but it was public school
children I think they really benefited
being around other children so maybe I
would pose for my children as long as
there were enough opportunities in the
place I'm living for them interact with
other students because socialize do
strange stuff underneath the bleachers
all of that I went to public school too
roaming I cut you off I'm sorry no yeah
that's socialized socialization is so
important and you know if there's one
down I just was bad Bethenny you're
you're actually doing it yeah yeah I
mean my oldest is four so we're just
sort of it's play-based now but yeah I
mean I you can be social there's lots of
social things to do in your
homeschooling but I see especially the
transgender stuff these days and I also
just see that the education is really
in schools and there it's not
evidence-based we we know from research
that kids perform better if they start
learning how to read later and instead
we're teaching kindergartners how to
read instead of first graders and we
just keep on pushing all of those
academics on earlier and earlier and so
my kids are home and they're playing and
that's how they're learning and my kids
are brilliant I'm just gonna say it and
you're saying that as as their teacher
in their mother yes this seems there
might be a conflict here but I don't
know oh yeah I know them better than
anyone else and I care about them more
than anyone else so their education is
every like that's what I live for and
they're I mean teachers are lovely and I
know many of them but my kids aren't the
most important thing is in their lives
and they shouldn't be but they are are
to me absolutely
okay we need to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube I know you're saying Michael
the ladies just got here too bad guys
you have to go to the daily wired.com
right now you need to pay $10 a month or
$100 a year and you'll get everything
you'll get my show you'll get the Andrew
Clavin show you'll get the Ben Shapiro
show I don't have one on me right now
but you will get the leftist here's
tumblr the finest receptacle for
drinking anything in the country but
especially delicious salty leftist ears
you can serve them hot or cold they're
always delicious go over there right now
you get the rest we have so much more to
talk about daily wire comm we'll be
right back
[Music]
okay following North Korea's sixth
nuclear test in recent weeks President
Trump has given the go-ahead for Japan
and South Korea to buy a quote
substantially increased amount of
military equipment from the United
States and here is president Trump
explaining his decision always BBC
closing always be closing always be
closing
talk about the art of the deal North
Korea sets off nukes and Donald Trump
sells the more of our military equipment
well done sir well done
roaming we have been asking this
question for weeks now are we heading
for war you know I would love to say no
but it's kind of getting increasingly
hard before that I was just looking
online and I saw Nick Haley came out to
the view and she statement saying and
you u.s. doesn't want or but at the same
time you can't expect us have unlimited
patience that comes North Korea and I'm
just not very optimistic s I mean I'm
hoping that it doesn't you know escalate
its all-out war or the west coast
especially not with you guys over there
but I'd be nice right yeah
especially I mean I hear this Doggett
Studios yeah I I'm not very optimistic
about it leading to some sort of
military confrontation kasi the United
States is so politically divided it is
so polarized I've I haven't seen it
since the last time the sore-loser
Democrats didn't win an election in 2000
it is as bad as that was can we even
effectively wage a war together right
now there were a real threat like a
nuclear North Korea are we too divided
to fight it
well I don't necessarily think there's
going to be a war but if your were to be
a war I think it would be the only well
together and even then I'm not
optimistic at all people are coming out
uh insulting Donald Trump for being
against Kim jong-eun I think they called
Trump they put on the same level and
called mode dictator fascism just mango
Mussolini is one of the terms I don't
like it but it is funny you guys are
talk about death camps earlier and then
you have them compare you are president
of a democratic nation ladies I bring
you on to cheer me up
and all you do is make me fear for my
imminent nuclear death Bethenny you know
a little bit about North Korea you've
been working in these charitable ways
for a while the problem just keeps
festering we've had this issue for 25
years now three or four four
presidential administrations do we need
regime change now so the scary part
about regime change there's really no
winning North Korea which is the scary
sorry
it's depressing all right well I'll see
you later guys there's gonna be roaming
nukes if there's a power vacuum
anyone can swoop in and grab those nukes
that was that was roamings band in high
school by the way roaming oh yeah we're
so cool I painted their fingernails
black and everything I'm sorry I got you
really gone mm-hmm and it is really got
that's a really goth moment and like
international affairs yeah so I mean
there's the roaming nukes or you have a
situation where it's just the
continuation of the situation that we
have now which they can blackmail us
continually forever and there's again
these death camps where millions of
people have died over the course of the
regime over three generations of Kim's
and it's disgusting and I mean honestly
now we're at a point where can we go in
there and change things that moment
might have already passed
you think it's passed militarily or you
think it's passed because culturally
it's also embedded both of them cuz I
just think why can't we go kill the guy
I mean there's a moral and and this is
something that makes me such a neocon we
have a moral imperative to stop mass
death I just I think it's and the only
time America has ever done that was Bill
Clinton in Bosnia we let Rwanda happen
we let
Cambodia happened we've let North Korea
happen for decades now and we certainly
let the Holocaust happen at what point
do we as the better people in the world
say this is not this is not an
acceptable situation there can't be
death camps there can't be mass
starvation like there has been in every
continent and on the flip side are
Americans willing to sacrifice their own
lives to liberate North Korea I don't
know I don't know if we're there after
15 years of war there is that political
so there's the cultural and the military
issue and then the political issue here
at home yeah I mean I I would like to
think that America is were made of
better people than that and I would like
to think that my sons would go over
there and say you know what this is this
is something worth fighting and dying
for the Liberty and life of people who
are trapped in these camps and trapped
in this Thorat Aryan regime in darkness
that's worth fighting for and we don't
seem to leave that and that's really sad
you may say I'm a dreamer but I'm not
the only one and speaking of dreamers
they are the top news today President
Trump announced his decision on
President Obama's executive amnesty
program daca which spells the
deportation of the so called dreamers
the illegal immigrants who entered the
United States as children or under 18
President Obama unconstitutionally gave
them de facto amnesty and now it looks
like that is going away Bethenny there
are 800,000 of these people in the
United States are we really going to
deport all of them or is that this is a
bargaining chip for Trump basically it's
a bargaining chip for Trump and the
frustrating part about this car I really
am going standing like such a chopper
but something about the vibe that Mike a
little studio brings it down I mean I
just feel like someone should be saying
these things and if no one is going to
be is no if no one is going to do this
and I guess I'm stuck being the one
doing it and I'm not happy about it but
this was an unconstitutional program
that President Obama set up and then got
all of their names and all of their
addresses he set this up what what it
was ever thus White House was
what did you have every ounce of blame
it goes with him on this yeah because
for all of the other bad things it does
it incentivizes more illegal immigration
that during that process by the way
eighty percent of women and girls are
raped sixty to eighty percent depending
on the study but they're feminists
they're nervous they're looking at we're
waging the war on women yeah but there's
that and then it's a simple issue the
program is unconstitutional yeah you
should have gone through Congress and
Obama himself actually said that but
when Congress didn't want to act he
decided you know what I'm just gonna do
this myself and you know I I don't think
the Trump might be going about this the
right way but he was dealt a crap card
and no one no one in the media and no
one in in this sort of immigration world
is really being honest about that and
Americans recognize that and this is how
you got Trump they're all very confused
exactly right that's like that when I'm
on Twitter it says like this is why I
was elected in it's Trump pointing up
yeah so roaming if President or of the
deal is just negotiating here and he
offers say to go a little easier on the
dreamers in exchange for something like
the wall would the Democrats take it I
don't think so right now I don't think
they're in a place to negotiate I mean
if you think about the Democrats
respective anything to do with dreamers
is on Fox right I mean Trump is kind of
a no-win situation so you know with that
if the does offer a bargain well guess
what else was catchable popular at the
wall so if Trump ends up taking a weight
back and trying to build oh well that's
just kind of I'm in a better position at
least one debate for the next election
so I mean I hate to console if I were a
Democrat I'd be yeah let's see how
strong can do to who upset anyone on I'm
sorry I'm still getting over roaming
millennial saying if I were a Democrat I
can't it is just so unfathomable we now
need to move on again a teacher this is
the most important news of all it's my
favorite story a teacher at George's
River Ridge High School recently made
two of her students leave her classroom
the crime they were wearing make America
great again t-shirts now
were they wearing t-shirts supporting
the current president they worry shirts
that simply said to make America great
again
and the kicker of course is that that
teacher has yet to be disciplined
roaming public teacher unions are among
the strongest political entities in the
country actually not terribly strong in
Georgia but around the country where
Bethenny and I come from there they're
the most important political force that
exists
they're also inherently corrupt because
public unions are just the government
negotiating with the government Samuel
Gompers opposed them FDR opposed them is
there any argument not to decertify
these unions how do we get rid of these
this inherently corrupt process well I
think there are a ton of reasons to not
be certify them if you are part of the
Union yeah if you're a teacher that I've
spoken to some teachers and actually I
used to be a professor at a sajak which
is the college in Quebec and there are
actually quite a few aren't as clearly
in favor of having to pay dues and
feeling like the union doesn't really
represent themselves just the union
leaders ha but it's it's hard because
like you said it's there barking spells
right it's publicans they're unionized
again and so you know we asked
right-to-work legislation I and there's
always a sort of fuss made are the
unions of but at the day it's better for
workers it was better for us as
taxpayers I think so hopefully one just
needs coverage and they're willing to
bite the bullet and what may be done
will be better in the water
Cassie you're a product of public school
as am i these public teach as is bethany
these public teacher unions are we just
drag him through the mud we drag them
through just like the we direct them
media or are they getting short shrift
or are they really as bad as we all say
that they are
obviously think they're pretty bad you
look what happened Wisconsin what Scott
Walker did was amazing things are doing
a lot better than Anders s floors are up
I think what's going on right now or
these unions are trying to stay relevant
which is what the left is doing every
single political institution that is
liberal is trying to stay relevant by
doing this they're they're shameless
outraged and trained and somehow grabbed
power because they lost all the power we
have all the governorship so you have
all those state legislators you have the
majority of everything and so I think
there's a a ticket try not to drown fair
enough Bethany I think everybody has
convinced me someday when I have a
little brood and army of Knowles's will
you be one of their home school teachers
no but I will talk to your wife about my
curriculum of choice that's fair enough
little Michael's all running around
smoking cigars and yeah you know it
would be a lot to handle
okay we have got to go now my wonderful
all-female panel of deployables thank
you for being here roaming milena bell
Cassie Dylan and our in-studio guest
Bethany Mandel thanks for having this is
the Michael Nolt show I'm Michael
Knowles come back tomorrow and we will
do it all again
[Music]
you
[Music]